the term cuckolding is related to the
cuckoo bird that lays an egg in the nest
of other species and then that egg
hatches sooner and then the cuckoo chick
consumes the food and the resources of
the other species and early naturalists
looked at that and said well that's what
happens if a guy's wife cheats on him
the man is at risk of investing
resources in a child not genetically
related to him
cook holding why did you get into that
why did well uh to be clear why did I
get into writing and reading and
researching about it and working with
people that engage in it
um uh back in like 2007
um I was clinically depressed um I in my
day job so to speak I run a large you
know Community Mental Health Center
agency uh traditional Behavioral Health
Services lots of Medicaid HR budget all
those kinds of issues
um and it was really challenging I was
really struggling so
um I I started collecting data for a
study about uh consensual non-monogamy
at the time very little had been
published about polyamory
Etc and uh I never published the study
it was a it was a crappy little study
probably not very good anyway but as I
was doing it I ran into these two
couples who lived the cuckold or hot
wife lifestyle where the wife was uh
enthusiastically
um you know sexual with people outside
the relationship with men outside the
relationship and the husband was
monogamous
and my initial impression and reaction
was honestly to say wow that
that's crazy that that can't work
um but what was really remarkable was
that uh both of these couples had been
married for decades they had incredibly
successful careers uh very healthy you
know kids families
um incredible communication skills by
every measure that we would as a
therapist you know apply
these were very healthy people and so
then I I kind of questioned myself I was
like well why did I assume that that
they're unhealthy and and at that point
you know I've been working around
sexuality issues for a while but but I
realized that without noticing it I was
applying moral biases around female
sexuality around promiscuity around
monogamy and those biases had snuck into
my clinical thinking
and so I uh went to the literature and
there was nothing published about this
there was there was one study in the 90s
by his Israeli psychologist who analyzed
you know letters to Penthouse about wife
sharing and
um there's nothing else nothing else
published about this and then as I
started you know talking to people I
started hearing how common this was and
so I dove into literature
um evolutionary psychology uh it's a
psychology of monogamy biology of of
sexuality female sexual arousal um uh
and I also interviewed people
um around the world who were living uh
this this lifestyle and and at the end
of the day I found that you know there
were actually lots of people who
clinicians like me who
um assumed it was unhealthy because
they'd never been taught how diverse
sexuality is
um and uh the fascinating thing is I
mean you know when I wrote the book um
nobody was really talking about
cuckolding but over the past few years
it's really exploded I mean we've got
you know the Jerry Falwell Jr Scandal
um multiple folks around the Trump
Administration actually involved in
cuckolding and
um it's super popular in pornography now
uh and we didn't see any of that coming
um and and my book insatiable lives on
the topic um was re-released as an
audiobook last year and it's just like
flying off the shelves on Audible
because people love to go on these road
trips with their wife and pop that in
and then say hey what do you think
there is a very large cohort of men that
are listening right now who are thinking
[__] no how is a man able to get past
his inherent uh concern around his wife
going off with another man we are
evolutionary programmed for male
parental uncertainty to be something
that we are incredibly fear scared of
right how is this something not only
that a non-insignificant group of people
men can deal with but can actually take
pleasure from
it's a really interesting question Chris
and it's it's one that you know I'm
starting to think we need to research
because you're right there there are
many men that when they the fear of
infidelity by their female partner
triggers rage and even you know
murderous behaviors
uh
fear of infidelity is really common in
in spousal homicide
but then there are these other men that
the idea of their wife being unfaithful
turns them on
what's the difference between these guys
right now we don't know
um I I will speculate that uh some of it
is about openness to experience
um uh
there may be some some kink in this
um many of the The Men Who explore
cuckolding
um are interested in submission uh from
a bondage and discipline kind of
standpoint but not all
um
as there is what's really interesting
though is that
The Men Who grow up in highly uh rigid
stereotyped masculinized kind of uh
environments
are actually more likely to be turned on
by the idea of cuckolding because it's
an Escape From the constrictive rigidity
of in order to be a man you know you
must be so manly that your wife would
never even want another man
and there are lots of guys that you know
find that pressure kind of a burden and
they they want to escape from it or at
least a vacation from it and cuckolding
and the opportunity to kind of sit back
and sort of Watch
um is is less pressure for these guys
now interestingly
um you know cuckolding and fantasies of
cuckolding appear to be more common in
Republicans than Democrats they appear
to be more prevalent in uh highly Macho
kind of societies Brazil Russia what's
the data that you're pulling that sort
of stuff from
um a couple of different sources one uh
Justin Lane Miller is a psychologist
um a co-author with me on some research
around here Twitter follow everyone
should follow Justin absolutely and he's
he's got data on the prevalence of
sexual fantasies
um related to politics and and political
stances um is that self-report
uh fourth yeah self-report four thousand
I mean how do you how would it be
otherwise we I mean I'm not sure how we
would measure people I didn't know
some implicit bias [__] on a
computer oh joy yeah okay great yeah
yeah I don't know but okay yeah cool so
you've asked a non-insignificant sample
of people about the sexual fantasies and
in that cook holding appears to show up
how much how much does it show up
um you know in Justin's research I want
to say he found that uh oh there's a
siren going by sorry that's fine
um in Justin's research I want to say he
found about 50 to 55 percent of men were
reported that they had had at least one
fantasy of watching their female partner
with another man around 45 percent of
women reported uh that they were
interested in being watched with another
man by their partner dude that is
unbelievable like I I don't deny that
Justin has got the the data to back this
up but I just think
how is there more than 50 of men not
only that but there's ten percent more
men that want to see
their wife get [__] by another man or
at least a fantasized about it once and
the difference between maybe thinking
about it right and going through with it
is literally a universe apart right you
know there's a lot of things that we
think about doing that we don't right
and you know sexual fantasies are
cognitive exploration
um they oftentimes are a way we kind of
work through things
um in a Dan Savage um also a co-author
with me on some research around
cuckolding um he uh he argued that the
cuckold fantasy is an eroticization of
fear that because men are afraid of
their wife cheating on them that in
order to take away the sting of that
fear they eroticize it and turn it into
something that is that they then
sexually fantasize about or sexually
aroused by I think it's an interesting
idea but we don't see very many people
you know eroticizing spiders
um and as a way to deal with their fear
of spiders so I don't know that the
eroticization of fear strategy is is is
really a good explanation I think that
there's a lot of explanations now I did
when I wrote the book
um most of the men that were into
cuckolding uh were men that already had
kids and so you know you mentioned
parental uncertainty a minute ago and
you know the it it's interesting to
recognize that the term cuckolding is
related to the cuckoo bird that lays an
egg in the nest of other species and
then that egg hatches sooner and then
the cuckoo chick uh you know consumes
the food and the resources of the other
species and even will like push the
other eggs out of the nest an early
naturalist looked at that and said well
that's what happens if a guy's wife
cheats on him
um that now the the the the man is at
risk of investing resources in a child
not genetically related to him so they
called it cuckolding
um at the when I wrote the book
um in 2009 uh most of the men that were
into it already had kids
and I didn't see very many young men
that were into this fantasy and
interestingly just in 10 years we've
seen a big shift um and I'm seeing more
young men that don't have kids that are
interested in uh cuckold porn and cocoa
fantasy and even cocoa Behavior so that
to me the first instance that you had
would make a lot of sense because you
would think if male parental uncertainty
is no longer a concern right these men
will be insulated at least in part from
this fear I mean again for me it is
still dude it is absolutely blowing my
mind that there is not more than like a
a tiny tiny handful of guys that can do
this there's a famous YouTuber who um
put a video up last year uh tried
swinging uh went to a sex party of some
kind and he tells this relatively
in-depth story about watching his
girlfriend that he loved next to him
with some other guy and he said that he
just had to immediately leave it had
traumatized him so much to observe the
girl that he was in love with having sex
with another man and it's kind of become
a bit of a meme on the internet but I
you know
some of my friends are incredibly open
with regards to their sex lives I don't
think that they're particularly
repressed but I know that if that was a
situation that occurred one of two
things would happen they would leave and
get out and be traumatized or they would
smash the guy to bits like those are the
only two options that they have and I
think
I wonder whether
I wonder what is occurring to down
regulate that response maybe it is this
um like you say this eroticization of
fear I can see that as a thing and I
think that uh the difference between the
spiders and the
um cuckold fear generation is that that
is already within the domain of sex
right spiders aren't within the domain
of sex but watching somebody else have
sex with your partner is uh and also the
taboo transgression thing you know it's
the high-powered Boss [__] CEO woman
who loves to be tied up on an evening
time by her hot Playboy because there is
something about the polarity that
creates that that attraction right
that's what is exciting about it it's
letting go of whatever you are the role
that you have to play out there I think
right for instance one of the side
effects that you're going to have of BLM
over the last three years is probably an
increase in race play in the bedroom as
you make uh race a more taboo subject in
public I think in private you're
absolutely going to see this go up
all of that rolled together all of the
all of the all of the things I just
think it is such a fundamental fear that
men have for this to occur and it blows
my mind that guys can get past it and
that fundamental fear though comes comes
with a lot of energy
and that that's one of the things that
that I see in these couples is that they
take that fear and that jealousy
and they translate it uh transmuted even
into this kind of turbocharged sexual
excitement I mean we a guy is
interestingly when a guy believes his
female mate may have been unfaithful he
is more likely to have more vigorous sex
with or thrust more deeply and harder
and more likely to get aroused and and
and and want to have want to have sex
again right now some of this is the
sperm competition theory that uh some
research around it is not replicated but
I still think that that that
evolutionary drive to compete
um is part of what uh folks are using
here and kind of co-opting it in this uh
strategy to increase their excitement
have you seen any evidence suggesting
that this could be some repurposed
repressed homosexuality that men could
want to perhaps be involved with another
man but he's currently got a wife and
the closest he can get to a man is
letting her have sex with another man
and if you were to do some eye tracking
during that event you might find that
his eyes are on him more than her right
um absolutely I mean first let me let me
say you know as with any sexual behavior
um this is complex there are lots of
different factors and reasons for each
individual person that drive them into
this
um or or make it arousing for them but
you're absolutely right for a
significant portion of these guys there
was some suppressed bisexuality remember
that most of these guys are coming from
more conservative uh political or social
backgrounds where being bisexual or
having same-sex interest it isn't
acceptable but you know you can have sex
with your wife with another man through
the vehicle of your wife's body
um interacting with
um with his penis actually or
interacting with his semen by going down
on her afterwards
um you know a friend of mine on YouTube
uh runs the the [__] yeah Friendly Fire
um web uh account where he shares porn
of guys you know interacting with each
other sexually as they are having sex
with a woman and there's a lot of you
know uh
bisexual
um kind of interest in there that is
coming out in these is soft bisexual
behaviors what was the proportion of men
that had some sort of bisexual
inclination can you remember
ah you know we didn't
um I didn't collect numbers on that with
these with the research that I did for
my book it was it was much more
qualitative kind of research
um I I would roughly guesstimate that
bisexuality is probably 30 or 40 percent
of guys that are into into cuckolding
um now Joe court is a psychologist and a
friend of mine
and he he points out that there are guys
who have sex with other guys when
they're not motivated from a bisexual
kind of place and I I've questioned that
but Joe has a good example of a guy who
you know is not bisexual and not
attracted to other men but he's very
into being submissive and so if his wife
or a dominatrix forces him to have sex
with another man Even though he's not
into it for the other man he's into it
because that is the ultimate level of
submission and so it is erotically
arousing not because of this not because
of the guy but because of the submission
that is one hell of a level of
submission and wow dude some of the
um like corners of the internet with
Kinks I didn't think that I was
particularly vanilla sexually but dear
God like this this makes me think this
makes me think I don't okay so well you
know that and that remember where I
started that because most therapists and
most people don't know this 90 of
therapists and psychologists and mental
health clinicians in the United States
have almost no training in sexuality so
we've always assumed that vanilla is the
norm
but uh it's not that vanilla yeah well
it's not it's not I'm not I'm not that
vanilla right I'm relatively vanilla but
we what we know now actually research
from from Quebec
um uh in Canada
um has found that around 50 percent of a
normative population non-clinical
population have interest in things like
exhibitionism sadism masochism
um voyeurism
um things that we used to think were
disorders and about 30 percent of people
have engaged in those behaviors and so
what we're finding now is that the norm
is actually much more diverse than we
ever believed but people kept their
mouth shut because they didn't want to
be shamed for it the sexual Overton
window perhaps is a little bit wider
than we might have first realized okay
hot wifing what's hot wifing
um hot white thing is this uh kind of
offshoot of cuckolding
um kirkholding typically involves a you
know more of a submissive stance by the
male where he is you know taking a a
submissive uh role to to his wife and
her the men that she may be with
it looks a little bit more like swinging
where the husband is not in a uh
submissive rule but is sharing his wife
with other men
um now we're also now hearing about
something called stag Vixen and that is
roughly looking like you know hot wife
kind of thing but the man is really
taking a um a stance with that label and
saying I'm not a cuck I'm not being
humiliated I'm not weak I'm strong by
sharing my wife with other men and some
of this relates to the you know the
politics over the past few years where
Republicans and people on Fox News and
everything else were calling each other
cuck if they appeared weak at all and so
I think that guys then that were
interested in sharing their wives didn't
want people to take that as a as a
coming from a place of weakness
does cook holding ever go wrong and
destroy a relationship
absolutely I mean I've I've seen
um I've seen couples where uh the
husband was was really obsessive and
um the the focus or fantasy of of
cuckolding
um became so obsessive and dominant in
his relate in his sexuality that the
wife
um reacted negatively and and in some
cases even divorced I've seen some
cuckold couples where uh the wife falls
in love with the other guy and leaves
um that's the fear
um I think that as with any
non-monogamous relationship it can be
done right and it can be done poorly
typically the relationships that I see
fail
um for cuckolding fail for other reasons
and the cuckold uh you know fantasy or
behavior kind of just exposed some of
those cracks in the relationship and
what we found in research uh with gay
cuckold couples was that in general
um if it was a healthy couple and that
exploring cuckolding was a healthy uh
aspect to the relationship
what is different about gay or lesbian
is there such a thing as female cook
holding what's the reverse do women have
fantasies about watching their husband
have sex with another wife some it's
called cut queening um and it's spell
it's spelled kind of funny
um instead of q-u-e-e it's spelled
q-u-e-a for some reason I'm not entirely
sure
um it's it's much much much less common
um than the fantasy of cuckolding but
yeah there are
um wives who get aroused at the idea of
their their husband with other with
other women
um and you know I is that it
one of the things that that we see
happen in a lot of non-monogamous
relationships and in cuckolding
especially and and queening I guess is
that the more attractive your partner is
to other people the more attractive they
become to you right because and yeah
there's a lot of you know talk online
about you know women being interested in
men that are attracted attractive to
other women right
um is that some of it maybe
um I I I called it the queen bee um or
the or the or or the king B kind of uh
phenomenon in my book where you know
having having a partner that is
attractive to other partners and that
you can share with them but then you get
to take them home
um feels kind of rewarding and exciting
and fulfilling
what I'm thinking about is how
wild and interesting it is that on
average females show more bisexuality
than males there's more gay men but
there's more bisexual women in the world
and ancestrally
polygyny was more common than what's the
what's the one where it's one woman
polyandry thank you
um so we have you know at least some
ancestral uh predisposition to this one
man many women we also have a increased
preference amongst a non-insignificant
cohort of women for women compared with
men for men at least one you've got uh
the bisexual relationship
and yet you're saying that
Queen being whatever it was called uh
female queening or whatever is
significantly rarer than the thing which
seems to be statistically in terms of
sexual preference less likely and
ancestrally in terms of predisposition
less programmed
that's so interesting it it is all super
interesting and
um
we don't know what it looks like
um in in societies where there is
greater egalitarian sexual economics in
the polygamous history
reproduction and mating was oftentimes
women's only kind of economic value or
resource that they that they controlled
um so you know I know you know Jordan
Peterson got got in trouble by talking
about you know the the we should have
you know socially informed economy right
it didn't use the word socially which
was the problem that was why you got in
trouble right and you know and and he's
got a point because historically you
know polygamous societies had higher
rates of violent crime because you had
powerful men that had all the hot checks
and you had lots of young men who
couldn't date or mate or reproduce and
so they had nothing better to do than
start trouble
um but again in that history in that
Historical Society women didn't have
economic independence like we have now
what's really interesting is that as
men's economic uh index goes up
infidelity actually tends to go down but
as women's economic
um
index goes up infidelity goes up because
no infidelity female infidelity so women
who are economically independent are
more likely to engage in infidelity
because they're not going to lose
everything they're not going to they're
not going to be destitute uh living in a
shelter well it can also be whether or
not it's great would it also be the case
that women who are more economically
independent are struggling to find a
mate hypergamously that's above and
across from them which means that it is
more likely they're going to have to
make down William Costello's got some
new data around this that suggests that
hypergamy is actually on the decline a
tiny little bit
however it's also going down in line
with female only infidelity which is
going
up in line with rates of domestic
violence right so all of this is sort of
uh cascading together and and and we we
see uh you know men who are married to a
woman who makes more than him are more
likely to engage in infidelity
um with that uh uh whether that's
insecurity now
infidelity oftentimes is motivated to
kind of fill some insecurity
um am I still attractive to other people
um do I have options
um can I explore aspects of myself with
other people that I don't get to explore
with my primary partner
um and so again you know the
that that's that that's the one concern
I have about a lot of evolutionary
arguments and and Costello is brilliant
he's a good friend of mine and I love
his research
but
um evolutionary arguments can be really
great Just So Stories that
um explain really complicated behavior
and as a psychologist as a clinical
psychologist
I want to live in the complicated land I
want to I want to I want I want to deal
with and recognize all of the multiple
things that are influencing these issues
and not reduce it to single factors yeah
I understand that I think um what's
happening in The Mating Market at the
moment with this sort of ever increasing
group of educated and employed women and
it is is pretty fascinating
um
and also terrifying at the same time one
other thing that I had in my mind with
regards to
cook holding generally and a practice of
non-monogamy more broadly and I've got a
ton of friends I'm here in Austin which
is like the non-monogamy capital of
America right yeah um but with the
heroes San Francisco uh there is an
element of
of fear that I have around a kind of
chesterton's fence analogy going on here
that there are things which can be
enjoyable pleasurable and even good for
the individual
but which can be damaging
uh when you smear that across an entire
Society you know for instance monogamy
is pretty good for societal stability
you know if you have it's a sexual
redistribution strategy if you do have
that polygenous Society you are looking
at young male syndrome you are looking
at higher rates of loneliness of reduced
Health span of reduced birth rate all
the way down
um I'm not saying that we need to start
enforcing like you can't do cook holding
in the comfort of your own home like you
can do whatever you want right um but I
do think that it's an interesting
whatever ethical or philosophical
question to ask you know we put warnings
on uh cigarettes we put warnings on
foods that aren't particularly healthy
for us
I don't know I wonder if there is a an
equivalent uh type of relationship setup
that could be enjoyable to an individual
but could be corrosive to them perhaps
in the longer term it could be corrosive
to them but we don't allow young people
we shouldn't allow young people to watch
porn like for a similar sort of reason
that exposing people to sexualized
content at a young age isn't necessarily
good for them there's just a thought
that I had in my mind
uh I think the the issue is that one
relationship type doesn't work for
everybody
and
um a lot of the problem here has come
from
a a historical approach that monogamy is
the only right way to do it and
the more taboo you put around you know
uh violating monogamy the more exciting
it's going to be for some people
um also the more social structures
require that or at least the the
appearance of it I mean I you know as
Dan Savage you know calls it monogamesh
turns out to be much much more common
than we've ever taught than we've ever
recognized
and uh again I think the
part of the issue is that when we when
we use the term monogamy we're we're
meaning sexual Fidelity but that's not
actually what monogamy means monogamy
means life partner what's sexual
Fidelity so uh not being not having sex
with other with other partners
um but you can be monogamous to the
definition of monogamy and still have
sex with other partners a lot of the
birds for instance swans and geese that
people have said oh they're so romantic
they mate for life well yeah they
partner for life but they still have sex
with other
with other animals in the species so 95
of birds don't have penises either I
think so I'm not sure how much we can
draw across
now you know a comment that you made
though just a moment ago is and I think
it relates you know should should kids
you know be allowed to watch porn or
have access to porn I think it's a very
complicating and and challenging
question what what some research has
found though is that the more Parents
try to prevent kids from seeing porn
the more the kids want to see it the
more the kids work to seek it out
um what we find is that the the kids
that are younger and seeing porn or
report seeing porn at younger ages
tend to be higher sensation seeking kids
already they are kids that were already
interested in sex and the reason they
saw porn was typically because they were
seeking it out at younger ages so the
you know the whole social dialogue right
now about
you know um uh the weather pornography
is damaging for kids or not
all kids are the same and the other
thing that we find is that the kids who
are harmed by seeing porn who learn
unhealthy lessons right they learn that
to have anal sex you don't need Lube or
prep they they learn that you know to
give a girl an orgasm you just jump on
and pump away these are unhealthy
lessons
kids that learn those unhealthy lessons
tend to be kids who think pornography is
realistic sex so kids that think
pornography is realistic sex tend to be
kids that have poor levels of sex
education or have grown up and Societies
or cultures or communities where you
don't talk about sex the way we can
protect kids from any harms from
pornography
is through giving them good sex
education Emily Rothman is in Boston
she's a psychologist and colleague
brilliant and she's got really
remarkable research on an evidence-based
strategy called porn literacy teaching
young people adolescents what porn is
and isn't what they should or shouldn't
learn from it and that
um remarkably has very very strong
success for preventing kids from
learning unhealthy lessons from from
pornography I think definitely given the
increased prevalence and ease of access
that anybody that's got a smartphone and
you know nine-year-olds ten-year-olds
now are getting iPhones for Christmas so
I don't know you put the parental block
on and you've got some smart kid at 12
years old but knows left on better than
their parents like what you're gonna do
um so in that regards I I suppose it's a
an in an unwinnable War uh I do think
that porn literacy would make a lot of
sense I do
there is something really brutal
unfortunate about the way that the human
mind works which has been so you've
brought up a bunch of times today
as you try to wall off a taboo the
typical response from at least a
non-insignificant cohort of people is to
try and seek that out more right I I
remember I used this story a few years
ago where
um if you've ever been stood with
somebody next to the edge of a cliff or
whatever and you just think in your mind
like I wonder what would happen if I
push them over and then you can't stop
thinking about that thought because you
think oh my God that's so terrible I
mustn't think about it I mustn't think
about it well I'm thinking about how I
mustn't think about it so I'm thinking
about it and you continue to refer
yourself from the thought you mustn't
have that being said as far as I'm
concerned exposing anybody that legally
can't have sex to videos of people
having sex seems to cross a line as far
as I can see
unless it is like very structured
therapeutically done in a an
evidence-based way with the blah blah
blah
I don't I I struggle to see how we would
be able to justify exposing kids to
videos and images of stuff
that they
that would be illegal for them to enact
yeah yeah this famous sex educator years
ago though he said
what if we taught kids
how to swim the same way we teach them
about sex we tell them well you can't do
it until you're a certain age
um we can't expose you to information
about it
um and you can hear us in the room
having a lot of fun but you don't get to
know what's actually going on until
you're 18 and then we throw open the
doors and you can jump in the pool how
many kids would drown
not advocating the kids see porn by no
means it's for adults
but I think that there's a very
significant kind of moral Panic around
this that is significantly exaggerated
um Alexander stulehofer is a Croatian
researcher who's looked at for instance
you know the relationship between uh you
know consuming violent pornography and
uh sexual engaging and sexual violence
specifically in adolescent males and
what he found was really interesting he
found that
young man who watched less pornography
were at greater risk of engaging in
sexual violence and that the the young
men who were interested in watching
sexually violent pornography actually
stopped watching sexually violent
pornography as time went on in this
longitudinal study that you know the uh
access to pornography correlates with a
very significant decrease in sexual
violence in our society and in every
society where this has been studied
there's a lot of fear about pornography
that is just like me when I was when I
was reacting to those early couples that
I saw that is based on morality and
these intrinsic kind of intuitive fears
but the data typically doesn't hold up
what are some of the other biggest myths
that people hold around Paul
well one of the ones that is you know
all over the internet right now is you
know porn induced erectile dysfunction
that watching too much porn causes
erectile dysfunction and so you've got
these guys saying well porn broke my
dick and and I can get hard when I'm
watching porn but I can't get hard when
I'm having sex with my trying to have
sex with my female partner it must be
because of pornography and there's
absolutely no scientific evidence to
support this and there's lots and lots
of evidence showing that you know
watching porn is always
going along with a certain Behavior
right jerking off and we we talk about
porn but we don't talk about
masturbation so whenever we talk about
porn we have to talk about masturbation
now masturbation and sex are two
different things
what we know is that
uh roughly half of men under age 45
around 40 percent of men
um will report at least one episode of
erectile dysfunction and the number one
predictor of that is anxiety anxiety
obesity drugs and alcohol and limited
sexual experience
um now watching porn and masturbating is
different from having sex when I watch
porn and masturbate I don't have to buy
the internet dinner I don't have to
worry about finding its clitoris to turn
it on I just have to push the button
um
but when I'm with a partner I need to be
mindful I need to restrain my own sexual
desires or behaviors and be sensitive to
theirs
and if you are an anxious person with
limited sexual experience that can be
challenging researcher just last year uh
showed that in men that have any sexual
dysfunction delayed ejaculation
premature ejaculation erectile
dysfunction the men are about 50 percent
more likely to experience symptoms of
that dysfunction during partnered sex
and not during masturbation because
again during masturbation you can sit
back and relax
so how do we how do we address that by
trying to reduce the anxiety by trying
to help guys learn to not be so penis
focused in their sex to learn in other
behaviors expand the definition of sex
but
for these insecure guys who are on these
chat rooms and no fap rooms and every
other darn thing where they're being
told if your penis doesn't work every
time then it's broken and you're less of
a man
it creates this anxiety shame spiral
that increases iatrogenically
the occurrence of that anxiety
heterogenically iatrogenic is when a
intervention that is supposed to help
something actually
um creates more harm so if you go in the
hospital for uh appendicitis and you get
your appendix taken out but then you get
a staph infection that's iatrogenic
where the healing actually caused
another problem so the intervention of
trying to prevent erectile dysfunction
appears to actually be increasing it and
now there's one group that we do one
group of men that we do see
struggle with erectile function when
they are with a partner
but not when they're watching porn but
it's driven by shame guys who are
ashamed of watching pornography are more
likely to have difficulties performing
or getting erect when they're with their
partner because they're ashamed of their
private sexual behavior a lot of this is
is the shame not the porn typically
watching porn and again accompanied by
masturbation
is an indicator of libido guys who watch
more porn have more sex this is data
that comes up consistently because
watching porn and masturbating to it is
an indicator of your overall desire for
sex and those guys overall are more
likely to pursue sex or value it
um and and so enact it in their life
if shame causes erectile dysfunction and
stopping porn stops the shame then truly
proximally stopping porn stops erectile
dysfunction
not so much because
um the there's this interesting
phenomenon of uh
uh it's called a flattening where um the
more conservative your attitudes are
about about sex and porn the more you
start to view any kind of uh sexual
stimuli whether it's Frederick's a
Hollywood catalog I don't know if they
make that anymore
um uh as as porn and we see this huge
number of religious men who identify as
addicted to porn but report that they
haven't watched porn in the past month
in fact there's a significant number of
religious men who identify as addicted
to pornography but have never watched
porn
so it's the porn starts to become this
stand-in for sexual desires or thoughts
that they feel like they're not supposed
to have the number one predictor of
identifying as a porn addict is not how
much porn you watch but whether you were
raised religious
um so when when somebody comes to me and
says they they're addicted to
pornography or they're addicted to sex
what that tells me as a therapist is
that they have thoughts and feelings and
desires about sex that they wish they
didn't have as a therapist I now want to
try and understand
why do you think you shouldn't have
those thoughts and what what do you
think those thoughts mean about you as a
person can we explore that the the the
the the
research on effective treatments for
people that struggle with these sexual
behaviors or desires is not actually
getting them to stop the sexual behavior
but instead engaging in cognitive
behavioral therapy or Acceptance in
commitment therapy which are strategies
that try to change the function of the
behavior and try to address the meaning
and the cognitions that we put to the
behavior you could imagine for
a large group of probably secular
probably mostly non-religious guys who
are in nofap subreddits and whatnot that
the choice between I have shame around
Pawn use and masturbation that makes me
feel like I shouldn't do it and it has
potentially caused me to perform more
poorly with a partner or make me feel
like less of a man I can go through act
or CBT
or I can stop watching porn and stop
masturbating for many of them that is a
much simpler easier to control more
immediate return so I can see I mean I
the evidence with regards to nofap I
don't know I mean there's some of it
that's a little bit overblown that
you're going to levitate and that women
can smell your pheromones and stuff like
that that does that did always seem a
little bit far out to me but I can also
see how
the level of shame that you have or the
level of self-judgment that you have
around anything
can manifest in as real of a way as you
want due to an expectation effect right
you know the placebo effect if we could
Boggle it would be the strongest effect
in Pharmacology and there's an
equivalent in psychology as well with
the expectation effect if you are
expecting to feel bad because of doing a
thing and you stop doing the thing the
alleviation of feeling bad by no longer
doing it is going to not be
insignificant
yeah again though
um what is the definition of the
behavior and so a lot of the
um a lot of the the the folks you know
online that want to stop masturbating
they unfortunately will now frame as a
relapse
um any sexual thoughts any any sexual
fantasies
um a wet dream that that biologically is
going to happen if you stop having
um Regular emissions uh your body is
going to get rid of old sperm by having
by having a nocturnal emission wet dream
the the the the the the
abstinence only goal
increases distress depression and
sociality
um unfortunately because it that shows
up in the data yeah yeah in study after
study and people that participate more
and more and more in these abstinence
only forums
um are are they're showing higher levels
of anxiety higher levels of depression
um and and more and more thoughts of
suicide it's unfortunate because
the goal the abstinence goal
it's not necessarily a healthy one right
um how many how many how many
ejaculations or orgasms should a man
have every month to have the most
healthy prostate right 22. A man should
have urologically recommended 22 orgasms
a month for the for the healthiest
prostate now my prostate effectively at
this point is Immortal um when I die my
prostate will probably live on for
another 100 or 200 years
there's no point at which
sex
being healthy
um people who have more sex live longer
now we don't know if that's because
healthier people have more sex or
because having sex makes you healthier
it's probably both but there's no point
on that curve where it all of a sudden
goes down where okay that's too much sex
it sex appears to be a very healthy
human behavior and masturbating appears
to increase
sexual desire increase testosterone
levels increase sexual performance P men
and women who masturbate more tend to
have more sex and tend to enjoy sex more
again there's a chicken and egg kind of
phenomenon they're hap they're
masturbating more because they like sex
because it's it it's a valuable
experience to them they're more
motivated toward towards it but sex is
also a muscle the more sex you have the
more you want to have sex the less sex
you have
the less sex you want to have and so
they're um uh the idea that you know if
I if I stop masturbating that then I'll
be a better lover
in in in sexual medicine is simply not
true
have you looked at how porn use affects
single people's drive to find a mate
um yeah actually um well I mean I have
not um uh but a guy named Sam Perry is a
researcher in Oklahoma and he's looked
at this and
um a really interesting paper dropped I
think just last year
um where uh basically you know looked at
the question of
um because porn is a cheap and easy
sexual Outlet
um uh does it you know is is it like
fast food so the guys
um will stop wanting the steak dinner
they'll stop pursuing marriage and found
no evidence to support it
that
um again watching porn is an expression
of of libido and desire for sex and uh
people who watch porn and masturbate
want more sex and
sex is different than masturbation
because in sex with a partner we have
touch and we have another person there
and we can smell them and all of these
things that all of these stimuli that
are not present in masturbating to
pornography so masturbating to
pornography is not something that blocks
interest or takes the place of uh sex
now I will give a caveat in that I do
see
people oftentimes where a man for
instance is choosing to watch
pornography and masturbate rather than
having sex with his wife and there's
this kind of idea then that you know the
porn and masturbation has become has
taken the place of sex with his wife but
what I consistently find in those cases
is a couple of things one is that the
couple stopped having sex as frequently
and so the guy is watching porn and
masturbating to compensate
um for the decreased sex frequency but
two
the wife is
um not interested in the same kind of
sex that the husband is interested in
oftentimes the wife is more shaming of
sex
um and Views masturbation as uh shameful
or immoral and so more and more and more
the guy is now faced with well
it it's not that I don't have sex but
I'm not sure I won't have sex with you
because of conflict in the relationship
or because of sexual mismatch
um Again Sam Perry found that
um early he is his early research in 17
he found that watching porn predicted
later divorce he went now he's a great
researcher and he went back to that
research later on
um as suggestions of folks like me who
were saying you know there's there's
more to the story and
found that if you separate out the the
variance of masturbation in those
couples that actually porn watching had
a neutral to slightly positive uh
predictive uh relationship with the
marriage but masturbation frequency
predicted later divorce now it's not
that masturbation is causing divorce but
masturbation in increases in
masturbation frequency reflect a
mismatch of sexual desire within the
relationship and it's that mismatch
that is causing the later divorce and
relationship problems typically you know
and this is this is my Mantra is that
you know porn related problems sex
related problems
overwhelmingly are symptomatic of other
issues and unfortunately when we focus
on the porn or the sex I call it the
sexy shiny object syndrome we get
distracted by this acts we blame the sex
or the porn for everything yeah I see I
see many men who come in and they're
struggling with porn and they're
watching porn too much and they identify
as porn addicts well these are guys with
OCD or really significant anxiety
problems that they're not treating
watching porn and masturbating is a
great way to turn off your anxiety for a
little while but they need other ways to
turn off that anxiety
um and they need help dealing with
anxiety but they get distracted and
people around them get distracted by
blaming the porn
what would you say to somebody that's
listening to this and says I don't like
my relationship with Paul and I don't
like my relationship with masturbation
um
what would you tell them
um so I see a lot of those guys and I
and I and I talk about this a lot in my
in my third book it's called ethical
porn for dicks a Man's Guide to
responsible viewing pleasure and
um
first I think that's actually a really
good question to ask yourself
unfortunately many people
don't think about their sexuality when
they're not turned on they don't think
about how they feel about their sexual
desires behaviors or interests when
they're not turned on now when we are
turned on
um our uh sexual disgust and our
discussed reactions go down
um our friend and colleague Diana
Fleischman has remarkable research on
this showing the relationship between
disgust and sexual arousal when we are
turned on we are less disgusted by
things that we find disgusting when we
are not turned on
so being turned on changes the way we
think
I want people to think about their
sexuality when they're not turned on and
I want them to think about how it makes
them feel about themselves
but then I also want them to ask the
question
where did I get that
is that right do I believe that many of
us were raised
with racist and sexist values homophobic
values
as children but many of us now reject
those values we we don't believe in
racism or homophobia or sexism so so our
values and our attitudes can and do
change
if you were taught that you know
masturbating made you less of a man
I want you to ask where you got that
idea and I want you to also think about
why did the people who told you that
think that what were they wanting now we
I I hate to say this because because it
sounds ridiculous but
in fact the Nazis
told Hitler Youth that they shouldn't
masturbate and that wanting to
masturbate made them less of a man man
because it was a way to create
insecurity that they could then
capitalize on and use to manipulate the
young men
churches I mean the Christian church
has has gotten thousands of years of
control over people by creating sexual
insecurity and by Framing masturbation
um as as unhealthy there's a remarkable
researcher in Israel named Jane vifradi
and he's he's got this incredible paper
um called oh God I can't stop thinking
about it and he actually showed that the
more religious a person was the more
they tried not to think about
masturbation and of course as you and I
have said multiple times today the more
you try not to think about something the
more you think about it and the more
distressed and anxious and ashamed they
became about it
so if somebody's telling you these
things
why
um you know Kellogg's Corn Flakes was
invented as a food as a bland food that
wouldn't trigger physical hedonic
pleasure and lead to people wanting to
masturbate and have more sex
because again there's this there's this
idea that masturbation somehow depletes
you
um Samuel Tissot was a Swiss physician
in the 1600s who first argued in
European literature that um masturbation
depletes men of some uh essential kind
of element
turns out not to be true
um turns out you know the the the the
stuff that comes out of your penis when
you have an orgasm It's Not Your Brains
it's not
um it's not energy
um and masturbation appears to be a very
very healthy behavior that has been
socially stigmatized
David ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do where should they go
uh you know you can find me on Twitter
um at Dr David lay on Instagram davidlay
PhD and I've got a website
davidlayphd.com uh it is important to
know though that lay is spelled l-e-y
not l-a-y sounds like getting laid
David I appreciate you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]